[Applause]
yes we're resuming the ride with the
next 10 awesome character introductions
ironically we get to see a lot of
villains this time around so strap
yourself in for one hell of a ride
however before anything else i'd like to
encourage you to subscribe to the
channel if you haven't already
all it takes is just a simple click of a
button and it will help the channel
tremendously without further ado
let's get the ball rolling
here's an underrated animated kick off
the list i've long been awaiting the
release of a drifter's sequel but can
you blame me though when the first
season gave us some epic introductions
like the one of this badass right here i
don't think there's a better way to kick
off this high adrenaline show than with
the introduction of shimazu in his
natural element
in the heat of a battle this is an
establishing character moment to show us
his determination and toughness there's
just no putting shimazu down
and that's quickly become the trait that
i'll remember him for thanks to his
impactful introduction with pedigree
like that
is it any surprise that we soon get to
see him make such large strides when he
gets issacied
[Music]
now before we continue i'd like to give
a shout out to the hottest rpg in town
gen shin impact this is an open world
action rpg that takes you to the magical
world of devat
a beautiful world ruled by the seven
elements as the player character
your job is to explore the world in the
hopes of reuniting with your long lost
sibling
meeting friends and foes along the way
and battling alongside them being able
to do all the exploring and interacting
with overworld objects is one thing but
by far
the biggest appeal for me in genshin
impact is the characters they just look
so
awesome i'm personally looking forward
to getting to know the new character in
the coming update
the cool sword wielder kazua this next
update also comes with some nifty stuff
like new weapons to collect in new
monsters to defeat the next update comes
with not just those new characters but
also events such as kaboom ball combat
and the legend of the vagabond sword
there's no better time to hop in and
embrace the hype and i'll help you get
started on your journey just check my
description box to the link and get
started in this epic adventure
a bright beautiful world and an amazing
journey awaits
up next is wamu's introduction in battle
tendency
[Music]
really i could extend this entry here to
the rest of the pillar men but this
character introduction is hands down one
of the best in jojo and i believe that a
number of jojo fans agree with that
opinion the scene of wamu awakening is
something that every jojo fan will
remember
i just like how he wakes up analyzes the
situation and then quickly just starts
killing everyone
awaken my masters is such an iconic line
and much of it has to do with the manner
in which wamu first appears in the story
so how about you do you think wamu
deserves a spot here amongst the other
jojo characters
for me i don't think that's even a
question
[Music]
i know he's barely advertised and this
could count as a spoiler but seriously
who doesn't know about akazan's
appearance in the demon slayer movie at
this point
yeah the actual boss fight in the movie
is not nmu but the upper moon akaza
see this is how you make a surprise last
boss in a movie that's about to end
the whole thing felt like one of those
surprise bosses in video games
and arkadza works magnificently in that
role in this appearance we get to see
his prowess as he fights rengoku in one
of the most beautifully animated fights
in modern anime movies
it's so good that i talked about it in
another video in this channel a grand
entrance
an eye candy of a last fight and an
emotional farewell leading to a
cliffhanger
you just couldn't ask for anything more
we have another memorable villain
joining the mix with our next entry
meruem honestly speaking there are a few
shonen villains as good as meruem when
it comes to the writing aspect of making
a villain
one can say that his writing and
development throughout the chimera
antarctic is just so much above the rest
but that's not what we're here for now
is it right
what we want is to see some dynamic
entries and goosebump-inducing
introductions
and thankfully meruem has that down as
well the king of the kimira ants
deserves nothing less than a memorable
entry
and we got that in the way he forces his
way into this world
then he wastes no time showing off his
mercy the streak by offering peggy
and acting like a true demon with his
heartless actions it's this character
establishing moment that sets the tone
for the huge shift that we see him go
through down the line
as far as character introductions go
this is one of the best ones
because of how impactful it is
one punch man second season may have
been a rather contested adaptation but i
think that everyone can agree on one
thing
garo had one of the most badass villain
entrances
ever in anime thankfully the anime staff
managed to put it off in that regard
after all in a show like one punch man
anything less would be a disservice to
an incoming villain
that has to be pushed what better way to
make your name known than by running
into the hero association headquarters
adjust raising hell
it's not like garo is an unknown figure
entering his arc he's been talked about
by bang already
but seeing his power in action is just a
different feeling altogether the heroes
they just had no
chance all of them just get beaten up by
garo setting forth an intriguing
showdown in the horizon for the other
heroes
just what are they gonna have to do to
defeat this renegade introductions that
open up a lot of potential questions
like that
they're the ones that are just the best
deva mata
attack on titan is up next and my pick
for the show is
kenny's first appearance yeah
[Music]
the first episode of attack on titan's
third season easily kicks things off
with a bang
with the introduction of kenny ackerman
you know it's about time for a new
villain who's not a titan
and who would be a better candidate than
kenny the ripper what really made this
moment
is the atmosphere having watched several
seasons before this
you can really feel that something's
amiss that amidst the tension and the
surprising calm
something just has to go wrong doesn't
it then it happens with a bang
nonetheless we finally get to see levi
react in rage as he prepares to engage
his former comrade before we cut to
black
wow in true attack on titan fashion a
season starts off once again with deaths
courtesy of the season's villain hearing
levi's scream still gives me chills to
this day
and it made for one of the best
character introductions of them all
[Music]
golden king gilgamesh is up next with
his fate zero appearance
besides sabre i think that gilgamesh is
up there in the upper tier of most
popular servants in the fate series
why because it's the unbelievably
arrogant and confident attitude
perhaps it's the core visuals of the
gate of babylon or
perhaps it's because of how prone he is
in making entrances
as magnificent as the one he did in fate
zero
it looked like it's going to be a moment
for our skull buddy here and he's ready
to shine as early as episode 2 of the
series
unfortunately he just has to run into
gilgamesh before immediately getting
upstaged poor guy didn't even have a
chance and was just utterly destroyed
snatching defeat from the jaws of
victory rip assassin you're calling all
but fate zero gilgamesh blows
everyone out of the water see you again
in heaven's feel
what would you do when you think you've
got control only to run into a true
force of nature just when you think that
you've got the whole parasite thread
under wraps
this guy shows up and makes minced meat
out of your precious men and weapons
that's just how i felt when i saw goto
make his first appearance
a true freak of nature the ultimate
parasite makes his presence felt by
making short work of yakuza members
in the end he's just testing his
limitations despite already being a
force of destruction at that point
it establishes him as a threat quickly
and it sets the tone for his true moment
of glory to come in the future
you know how almost all of the
appearances featured so far have
involved some dynamic entry some
impactful entrance you either see said
character enter the screen in a big way
kill off people or otherwise do some
badass thing one after another
all for one in contrast has none of that
in contrast to the first eight entries
that we had here all for one's entrance
is very muted in comparison
however the atmosphere that he brings
with him during said introduction more
than makes up for it
props to the anime team for perfectly
capturing the moment
with shots on the hero's scared faces
this is the ultimate villain of all
the anti-thesis of all might and the
most powerful enemy that they've faced
so far and their reactions say it all no
way can they afford to take on this guy
if you can make such an impact with
minimal acting and dialogue but the way
the anime brought out all those emotions
with such
little action make this one of the
greatest character introductions of all
within one piece's gallery of villains
there are some cool ones
some crazy ones and then there's some
straight up awesome ones
however in terms of having sheer power
presence i dare say the kaido is without
peer
that much is established with his
character introduction the narration
also makes the scene so awesome
giving kaido a lot of hype as he jumps
down and crashes onto the ground
you can just feel the pure utter
destruction incoming as the humongous
kaido just towers over everyone
before declaring war this is one of the
best villain introductions
ever it combines the categories that
make a villain appearance so impactful
kaido looks intimidating as hell there
was a lot of hype coming into this
introduction and he wastes no time
declaring his intentions
and with that we close our second list
on the top 10 anime character
introductions
we also got ourselves quite the gallery
of villains today didn't we if you want
to share your thoughts on the video and
the characters that you feel should have
made the cut
let me hear you make some noise on the
comment section below i'd also invite
you to join youtube memberships to gain
access to some exclusive videos and
other perks
my patreon is also linked in the
description box so if you're up for
supporting the channel you might want to
head right over there don't forget to
check out our sponsors game gen shin
impact links in the description i hope
you have a great week ahead and i'll be
seeing you next time
[Music]
you